well all right so the Four Corners who  drive returns today and tomorrow for  every one dollar donated Three Square  can create three wholesome meals for our  community our very own JC Fernandez and  Mercedes Martinez were out there today  helping out  be able to help out and help those in  need it just it goes so far it means so  much to us that you help out and we're  able to kind of Drive the cause and I  think that the misconception is is that  if you're poor you're the ones that need  the resources and it's not true a lot of  people were affected by the pandemic a  lot of people are looking for jobs and  literally your next door neighbors could  be going to three square and getting  help  all right if you'd like to donate you  can call in to the number right there on  your screen 702 889 show or you can go  online head over to threesquared.org for  concerns